HALF.
ALLEN MISSES A THREE.
GIANNIS G
THIRD ON THE KNICKS AS A UP.
COUNT THAT BABY AND A THREE
POINTS OPPORTUNITY.
EVERYBODY IN THE BUILDING LOVED
THTH
THE BEST THIRD QUARTER SCORE IN
THE LEAD. THERE IS ONE E  LEFT-.
THIS MAN.
OKEYDOKE.
KLEBER, DOWN IT GOES.
LITTLE DIPSY-DOO
ISH WAINWRIGHT KNOCKED DOWN A
COUPLE FINISH.
BROWN.
OH, OH MY GOODNESS.
THE RUN OUT
THE BACK.
WIGGINS BEHIND
JUST A GUESS.
>> Brian MAKER, E LAID IT GETT
AT SOME POINT.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A LOT OF
MOVEMENT HER THE FINISH.
OUTNUMBERED.LOT ANYMORE.
WHEN I RUN THE ROOM, I THINK
THAT THEY MIGHT ASAS TO
HIMSELF.
GARLAND.
ALLEY OOP>> John: HERE IS THE P
THE INBOUNDS PASS.
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK
NO LOOKING
THEN HERE COMFREE MONEY
FOR GARY TRENT.
HE MAKES FOURUR
LAMELO BALL CAME JUST